foreign
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving in storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show where we help
people
build wealth
do work that they really love and create
actual amazing relationships Jade
warshaw Ramsey personality is my co-host
today as we enter your questions about
your life and your money the call is
free and some say the advice is worth
exactly what you pay for it the phone
number is AAA
825-5225 that's triple eight eight two
five five two two five Frank is in
Myrtle Beach to start us off hi Frank
welcome to the Ramsay show
hey how are you better than I deserve
sir what's up
question um 53
for retirement
a couple years ago
I have a college fund for my kids
uh two kids 18 and 15. all all my cars
are picked up all four of them
um
uh I I have a small I got invested in
years wait a minute you cut out you know
you're cut out you have a small what
yeah
I have a invested or I have like a a
pension or retirement uh whatever you
want to call it the company that I
worked for I got vested for um working
for them for 13 years so I there's a
small amount of retirement that's going
to come from that okay
um so it's not much at you know 13 years
it's probably not going to pay out that
much uh I have some income property
what's your question
so at this stage in my life what can I
do to you know I don't you know the 12
years away what can I do this
the supplement my income to some of my
retirement was like I keep contributing
to a 401k or a Roth IRA and I've pulled
their money out for hardship several
times I've never been able to
just uh
just to pay bills and I mean I shouldn't
have done that I've made a couple
mistakes uh
doing that okay you have debt now
no debt the girl you have an emergency
do you have an emergency fund of three
to six months of expenses
Thirty thirty thousand okay so the
chances of you needing to pull out money
with the thirty thousand dollar buffers
close to zero isn't it have we not
corrected this problem
um
well sure should I be contributing to a
four of the Roth at this point yeah if
you're going to use the 30 000 to pay
bills instead of the Roth
if you have an emergency pop-up don't
cash out your freaking Roth again right
you use the 30k that's what it's for
right
yeah but our income's pretty low right
now it's only about 30 to 40 000
um for myself my wife's about 25k that
health problems haven't been able to go
full time I've never been able to really
contribute the mass of 401k
um and I can't right now either why not
well I think you can max out all you can
put in and I think you can max out your
Roth IRAs you guys need to tighten your
budget up into a written budget you've
got to do it you've got to do it I mean
you got you you said you're 63 I mean
dude it's time I mean it's like past
time it's time to do this right you've
got nothing better to do than pile all
your money in a pile in a 401k and Roth
IRA as fast as you can if you've paid
off all your debt and you've saved up
your money and you don't have 15 the
math ain't mathin to put towards
retirement exactly it's not a thousand
dollar income yeah you can sit down do a
written budget with your wife and the
two of you focus in and say hey we've
got to make up some lost time and you
can do it it is possible it's it's not
too late I mean you're not going to end
up with two million dollars from that
but you are going to end up with a good
nest egg and take that vested amount and
roll it to a 401k uh you need to jump
into ramseysolutions.com and click on
smartvestor Pro and find a smart
investor in your smart mess Pro in your
area and sit down with them
and you and your wife develop a detailed
game plan on how you're going to load
this puppy up
got some catching up to do yeah but you
can do do it they just gotta do it
he does
um it sounds like in the past that they
had that didn't have an emergency fund
and we're putting money in the 401K and
this is why people they people freak out
and we say when we first start our
program do not put money in your 401k
until you are debt free other than the
house baby step two and have the
emergency fund because you will use your
401k like he did that's right as your
emergency fund Dom yep it's played out
bad idea
not dumb person dumb idea that's right
yeah that's a different thing there so
yeah you've got to do these things in
that order that lays the foundation to
be able to win Michelle's in North
Carolina hi Michelle welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi thank you
um I'll get right to my question and
then give a little bit of background and
hopefully you can figure this out for me
um and so my question is should I have
additional money withheld from my W-2 as
a teacher to avoid owing money at the
end of the year as I have this year for
the first time in my life or focus on
paying down high interest debt
um and I have about twenty thousand
dollars of high interest debt you should
have the proper amount
pulled out of your check for taxes the
amount you're actually going to owe no
more right no less
that's the question then that that I
have how can for some reason they cannot
seem to figure this out so as
my employer oh that's not their job
okay how do I figure this out because I
don't know how much
um they should be taking out okay how
much extra did you owe this year
2100 okay and so that's suspiciously
like about 200 bucks a month
has anything changed in this year versus
last year for your tax situation
buy a house get rid of a kid
no longer got a depend on my son's 19.
so he was going to be the same as last
year they're going to be the same as
last year your income is going to be
about the same no big of financial
events that are causing a tax change
then you could simply tell Personnel to
change your withholding by 200 bucks a
month and you'll be okay
okay that's an easy way of doing it the
more complicated way of doing it is
actually sit down with a tax
professional do your taxes for this year
you're not going to file them but do
them and go I owe exactly this amount
divide that by your paychecks and make
sure that much is coming out of your
paychecks
and that would be exact the IRS
withholding tables are incompetent and
wrong they're from the IRS don't be
shocked it's terrible and and you're in
your you know and so you know I claim so
many deductions I'll never forget my
oldest daughter got her first job out of
college and uh she had to claim nine
deductions
and she had no dependents she was a
single college girl in an apartment but
she had to claim nine to get the right
amount of withholding there were there
the tables were that far off just stupid
so yeah that that's what you're facing
so you can't
Personnel doesn't know how to do it you
can sit with a tax professional and
figure out exactly and then take that
number go to Personnel say withhold this
from my checks or just change it by 200
bucks which is 2400 a year you'll get a
small refund next year if your taxes are
exactly the same as they were this year
but uh it doesn't look like taxes are
going to change much from 22 to 23. so I
think you're going to be okay doing it
that way but if you want to be perfectly
nerdy and do it the other way you can go
that way too this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
dread wash all Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
this is the Ramsay show Kate is with us
Kate is in Jacksonville Florida hi Kate
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave hi Jade thank you for your time
today sure what's up
um
clear or not I should pay off my
mortgage using some of my CDs and
Investments what kind of Investments are
they
um if they're Diversified with Capital
Growth they have Capital Growth cord
bonds those kind of things
non-investment it was a life insurance
I'm sorry non-retirement
um well it's kind of turned out to be
retirement no is it you know 401k or an
IRA
no it's with an investment company
um my my previous husband passed away
and so it was his life insurance policy
I'm so sorry
well he passed away during covet it's
been a few years but um
and that's it because I didn't know what
else to do with it
except for our home yeah except for our
home and um I wanted to pay my home off
but just in that time
um when I hadn't invested it okay and I
since remarried and we would just like
to use you know our money properly and
I'd like to kind of honor my late
husband
um because we both wanted to have the
people at home yeah
um
so I just I want to know if this would
be a good idea or if we should just
buckle down and pay off what is left
with the balances because I have
um very little and my interest rate is
super low what is the balance what's
your balance okay the balance is 164.
how much is in your Investments
um we have a net worth of 780. what's in
the Investments
um that's probably about a total of 467.
oh yeah so you could pull some out and
be mortgage free quicker than you know
it just know that you're going to be on
the hook for some taxes when you cash
this out right
okay well the CDs I guess not because
when they roll over I probably wouldn't
do it in a big chunk I'd have to you
know because they're rolling over at
different times I have about four
different CDs that I could pull from
about a hundred thousand and then
probably have to take the excess from
the fund so there may be a penalty with
that is that correct yeah there won't be
a penalty if you've invested in mutual
funds the only thing you'll have is
taxes on what it is increased that
you've not paid taxes on if you get any
capital gains on it that's all but your
broker can tell you that I I wouldn't
wait on the CDs to roll over I just cash
them out and do it I'd be dead for you
this week this week I'd be done
in the State of Florida she's 23. um
She'll always have to be under my care I
do want to give her a sense of
Independence we could build something on
the property that we're on this house
that we would pay off or if we could
eventually find something in the next
few years to move would it still be a
good idea to pay off this mortgage pay
off the mortgage this week
and then decide what you're going to do
with whether you're going to add on or
whether you're going to purchase is a
different decision and you're going to
do that later
okay yeah it doesn't it doesn't change
anything because there's no time that
you're going to lose money as a result
of having paid off the mortgage when you
if you sold this house and moved to
another one they're going to give you a
check at closing for all of the money
right it's not like you're consuming
this money you're moving it from
Investments to a paid off house from one
asset to another
and so the money doesn't go away it's
still sitting there and so if you two
years from now three years from now say
hey we're gonna go buy this neat little
place that's got our mother-in-law
apartment for our special needs 25 year
old by then
um yeah you can do you just sell your
house take the money out of it and use
that to purchase the next one maybe with
some of your other debt money or maybe
not but somewhere in there but pay off
your mortgage this week Kate this back
and forth worrying about this worrying
if you did the right thing is causing
you more angst than it's worth just make
a decision
pay off the mortgage and then you're
going to get you're gonna have a sense
of Peace just from having made a
decision that's right it's all this all
over the place that's driving you crazy
and you're wondering if you're doing the
right thing all the time and you are
doing the right thing by the way you
didn't do a dumb thing by investing the
money I think that's a very smart thing
to do you let it sit there while you're
going through the grieving process you
reset your life remarried now and wow I
mean you've gone through a lot in the
last 36 months
and you kept your head about you through
that so congratulations very very well
done Britain is an Oklahoma City hi
Britain how are you
hey Dave how's it going better than I
deserve what's up
so I got a question
um my parents raised me in a Dave Ramsey
home where
um now I'm 27 years old and I don't have
any debt on my house my cars you know
student debt anywhere man you got to go
home and kiss your parents on the list
you're 27 years old with a paid for
everything way to go great moms and dads
yeah but this is this is my question uh
I read somewhere Dave Ramsey's worth 600
million dollars
and I want to get into that kind of
wealth for my family and impacts that I
can make with that kind of that kind of
money
um so I don't know how I get to the
hundreds of millions of dollars with the
kind of money that I'm making now I
think if I stay disciplined and
conservative I can definitely be
multi-millionaire but
um hundreds of millions of dollars
without taking on debt I don't see how
I'm gonna get to that point I love real
estate my life my wife is a realtor and
that's what we were really looking into
a lot of projects in real estate but
what would you tell me I just don't know
time wise that's the biggest constraint
how do you get to that much well
well I think you said intermediate goals
number one number one I'm gonna work a
traditional plan and go for the first
five to twenty million and the
traditional plan that we talk about here
all the time I'll put you in that
category but no you're not going to
become a billionaire with your 401k it's
mathematically impossible
so um and what you've got to do in that
case is study billionaires for instance
you could comb through and say okay uh
the Forbes 400 are all billionaires now
you don't make the 400 anymore unless
you're a billionaire a billionaire is a
thousand million it's a completely
different Stratosphere okay and it's a
completely different discussion but you
asked so it's a fun discussion so what
we do is we study best practices with
study the Forbes 400. okay what do we
find there do we find a bunch of trust
fund babies nope
you don't find a bunch of inherited
wealth you find um
the true at Kathy family at Chick-fil-A
you find David Green at Hobby Lobby
you find
[Music]
um
Oprah
you find Bezos at the top you find
Buffett at the top uh you'll find
Michael Dell
okay you'll find uh all kinds of things
and so what do you find and all of those
are first generation Rich by the way
Walmart Sam Walton when he was alive now
that money is now dispersed to one the
next Generation down and I think each of
those members are still billionaires
pretty sure they are but that's that is
inherited wealth there because Sam the
old man started Walmart but it's Walmart
money so what you do find when you're
going through there and I've noticed
this is the vast majority of them are uh
it's like 69 percent of first generation
rich
okay so that means you can it's possible
in other words uh then number two how
did they do it well it wasn't funding
their 401K that's not that doesn't get
you to a billion a thousand million
doesn't get you there okay uh what they
typically did was start an Enterprise
start a business
so I mean you've got Gates starting
Microsoft you got Dell starting Dell you
got Chick-fil-A you got Hobby Lobby
you've got Oprah is an Enterprise
Oprah's not a brand Oprah is an Empire
uh a huge brand but it's got I mean
hundreds and hundreds of employees and
so uh yeah I mean I know she's a person
but she's also a massive Enterprise and
so uh that kind of so each of these
people uh the I
I think almost all of them started
businesses and the business made them
wealthy the the explosion of the
business
and or they took them public yeah and
the stock made them rich I mean
obviously
that's uh uh Buffett's situation
um Phil Knight yeah Phil Knight in Nike
yeah that's another one so those are but
they they almost all were business
enterprises and they grew large
businesses
um and in my case that's where my money
came from the vast majority of it is
from running from Ramsay I've got 1100
team members we do 300 million a year in
gross gross revenues here at Ramsay and
so yeah I mean obviously that's where
our my personal net worth came from this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
laughs
[Applause]
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
Jade walshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today hey thank you to all of
you who have subscribed and followed the
show on your local podcast or your local
uh YouTube channel thank you for doing
that anytime you subscribe anytime you
follow it helps us tremendously with our
algorithms and makes other people aware
this show is here there's tens of
millions of you out there looks like
we're approaching about 30 million right
now between talk radio and podcast and
uh YouTube uh a bunch of bunch of folk
there and thank you and the reason that
you're there is you told somebody so
share it
share the show tell them where you're
listening to talk radio tell them where
you're uh you know whether you're
watching on TBN whatever it is tell them
you're following YouTube whatever it is
click click the share link and uh where
appropriate leave us a five star review
we'd appreciate that very very much all
of these things help us we're not
spending 300 million a year on
advertising and marketing for the show
we don't have a football stadium named
after us that we paid for like uh uh or
somebody like that excuse me I got
allergies but the uh um but yeah the uh
yeah it's out there and so you guys are
our marketing thank you if you tell if
you love it tell people about it if you
don't love the show uh well spend your
time doing something else it's silly
don't don't be here that's right
anyway we appreciate you we're glad
you're here thank you for being with us
Nate is in New York hi Nate welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hi Dave how do you do better than I
deserve what's up
yeah so I guess my main question is like
I have a
uh the main question I guess is how
should I go about paying off my debt
what kind of debt do you have
so
um
yeah so I have uh about 48 Grand and
private student loans
and um
19 Grand in federal student loans
um I have a
uh about 12 Grand on my car
and I have a seven and a half Grand
personal loan
what's your income
yeah so my take-home pay right now is
about 2600 a month okay uh how old are
you
I'm 23. what do you do
I'm uh support technician for my
company's r d what'd you get your degree
in
math
okay yeah okay yes I so I had this
opportunity so uh I was admitted into uh
Masters in applied math program all the
way across the country
um and uh
but right now I have about like three
grand in my savings
and um
I also have about 2500 in a 401k I don't
know why I
put money in there
at this point right uh so uh I I do
you're a math guy and you understood
compound interest you wanted to get
involved that's it yeah but uh the the
equation here the equation here is
simple you've got a big hole of of debt
and your income needs to come up so we
need to be working on ways to get that
income up short term and long term right
you're just getting started 23 years old
you're just getting started
um I'm sure there's plenty of ways to
move up in the field that you're in
right
over time I think so yeah I think so I
my my my biggest so my the plan I kind
of have right now is I'm thinking about
just trying to get a second job and like
working as much as I can yep and then
like but I don't know if so next year by
next September like let's say I have
like you know 20 so right now I'm
staying with my grandmother and like uh
I'm I'm trying to not spend any money on
anything that's good
again let me go back the equation is
simple what we're doing here is we're
getting our income up in the short term
that's looking like working an extra
part-time job some side hustles and
trying to get this paid off as quickly
as possible another thing you can do is
make sure that you're writing down your
expenses and what you're spending
through your budget because that's
you're going to optimize your money in
that way so those are the two things
that you need to be doing lowering your
expenses through budgeting and
increasing your income through part-time
side jobs that sort of thing and that's
that is the only way to skin the cat on
this one you know there's no magic thing
Nate I took every math class that was
available to me all the way through AP
um math is my thing I love it so I love
the way your brain works it's the way
mine works and here's my warning don't
over Analyze This
okay I nowadays when I'm talking to
someone like you I use big math I call
it meaning very little analysis so what
I'm looking at is I just added it up
real quick in my head you got 86 000 in
debt and you make thirty five thousand
dollars a year
okay
86 000 in debt means you need to power
forty three thousand a year for two
years and you're debt free so what have
we got to do to do that you need to make
about thirty five thousand dollars more
than you're making right now and so
you're gonna lean in on your current job
push push push do anything you can do to
get promotions and move up or change
your current job to a better one and
you're going to work like a maniac at
the best possible paying side hustle I
don't care if it's cleaning septic tanks
or walking dogs do whatever you got to
do for two years and get your butt in
gear and go find you forty three
thousand dollars a year for two years
and you're done man you're 25 years old
and you're debt free the whole mess is
cleaned up and you will have learned
some things about Nate that you don't
know right now
you will like him even better because I
like him I think he's a good guy
do you think it's like worth it to take
uh the school opportunity you're broke
no you don't need a master's in Applied
Mathematics you need a job
right
you got to go get some money you have a
mess
yeah so Jade comes out 38 000 in income
with a couple of Music degrees did I get
that right you're about right and 465
000 in debt they did not get out of 465
000 in debt her and Sam in seven years
with thirty eight thousand dollars you
know what they did they got their butt
in gear you got to work man and they got
their incomes up and their income up
some more and their income up some more
and they were making serious money by
the end of the story but the beginning
of the story was pitiful in the
beginning of your story is pitiful but
the end of your story is going to be
amazing because you have that ability
my only like concern so there's like
don't analyze this Nate
quit you got you're getting paralysis of
the analysis already
you got to get in gear man you gotta
Roar it's a it's a simple simple
equation be a little Dumber for the
purposes of getting this done this is
just be a Workhorse you know just get
your butt in how much money can I make
legally and morally how much can I work
and don't worry you're not going to die
from over work right before you die you
pass out don't worry about it hey
there's this
um I'm sure you've read Atomic Habits by
James clear and he talks about the idea
of Motion versus action and the motion
is I'm reading all the books I'm doing
all the math equations I'm rolling it
over in my head over and over but the
time comes when you actually have to act
and do the things that you're reading
about thinking about listening to
podcasts about asking Dave's advice
about at some point the motion has to
transfer to action and that's the only
way that you're gonna get out of this
thing but I mean you and Sam just throw
your shoulders back and roared yeah you
just went
I'm going you know that's what you did
you have to you guys went and you worked
and and you did some crazy stuff that
was legal yeah but it was like you look
back on it you're like you you nuts and
that's what that's what Nate's got to do
you gotta you don't have kids you're not
married you can do crazy stuff like get
a bunch of Roommates so you're paying
pinch you know stay with Grandma for
free that's crazy right there you can do
things like you know sell everything
you've got you can get rid of this car
if you need to and get a 2 000 car
there's there's a lot that you can do
you can work to all hours of the night
you're 23 years old your body doesn't
you know don't get me wrong you need
sleep but I'm saying you can do you can
do the crazy right now and do it now
dude don't put this off until you know
10 years on Down the Line listen money
comes from action and work go get you
some that's right forty three thousand
dollars a year for two years you're done
and then call me up we'll have you come
down here you can stand on this debt
free scream we'll give you a big old hug
and tell you we're proud of you because
that's where you're going man that's who
you are you're you're not a wilted
Little Snowflake you're a roar man Roar
get it get it this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
we are people who tune into every
episode of the Ramsey Show they know
everything we teach about money they can
answer the questions faster than we can
and they still still feel stressed and
stuck because knowing what to do isn't
the problem
doing it
actually doing it is the solution
personal finance is 80 Behavior it's
only 20 head knowledge and The Proven
way to change your behavior actually
doing it with money is by taking
Financial Peace University the class is
the difference between trying to get
into shape on your own versus having a
personal trainer you'll have a
coordinator who holds you accountable
and other people in the class pushing
you and cheering you on and that's why
this class has worked for over 10
million people and after nine weeks you
will never handle money the same way
again you will make progress faster than
ever don't just listen to the show
commit to doing what it takes to win
join a Financial Peace University class
at ramsesolutions.com
FPU
ramseysolutions.com
FPU Melissa is with us in Portland
Oregon hi Melissa welcome to the Ramsay
show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
I discovered your program three years
ago and since then we have paid off my
husband and I a hundred and twenty
thousand dollars in debt and I proudly
drive a 2006 Honda Odyssey now
we have
um no debt other than our student loans
and our house but unfortunately
um I guess unfortunately my husband has
a private undergrad a master's degree
and a separate law degree how much is
that debt
we still have a hundred and ninety
thousand dollars in student loan debt
okay yeah and so I'm glad you're on Jade
too because I know you have a similar
experience so yeah well the student loan
debt yes yeah so what's your household
income
we have about a three hundred thousand
dollar household income that's good so
we have a big shovel a big hole as you
say
um but about half of our income is
um from I own a business I'm
self-employed so it's a little bit more
precarious I would say my husband's um
an attorney and is a little more stable
maybe so how can we help
yeah so our other
um numbers to share because I know Dave
will ask because I listen all the time
we have about 20 000 in liquid
um savings I like to have a little bit
more even though we're gazelle intense
just because I am self-employed I have a
one-year-old and a four-year-old and I
have three to six months no if they
still have a hundred ninety thousand
dollars in debt we still have 190 000 so
oh I see I see yeah yeah that but
because I'm self-employed
um okay so what's your question okay so
my question is we living in pretty
somewhat unsafe area without great
schools and my oldest son is going to be
in kindergarten next year and so we are
hoping to move in a year we have about
two hundred thousand dollars equity in
our house right now and I am but we've
still been just paying the student loan
debt um
the house is probably worth about five
hundred thousand
sounds like a rough neighborhood
half million dollar homes I live in I
live in Portland Oregon so the housing
prices are very high
um no they don't have they don't have
300 000 slums in Portland Oregon 500 000
slums
yeah I don't have them I've been there
yeah yeah
so my question is should that I mean I
think you're probably getting that we
should just stay
well Melissa I can take you and show you
some real rough neighborhoods
there's some real ones some real ones
yeah yeah it's just that my my I was
hoping that my son would not have to
move schools okay here's what I would do
here's what I here's what I did
I sold my home
and I rented
okay and I changed my kids schools we
had our kids in private school because
we were in a neighborhood where we
didn't like the schools
um nowhere nowhere near as long long a
lot longer ago than now but nowhere near
the same numbers you're dealing with
um and we sold the house and got it got
dumped the private school tuition and
rented for two years while we got
ourselves straightened up and got out of
debt and then we bought
that's what you should do you should
sell your house take the 200 000 pay off
your student loans
so I we were very close to doing that
last year and I to do that exactly take
the equity and pay off the student loans
um which we could do but our mortgage
right now is only 1600. well I sound
like I'm gonna argue with you
no I'm just wondering if the rents are a
lot more expensive you're not going to
have a mortgage you're not going to have
a mortgage you do what you want to do
Melissa okay you do whatever you want to
do
I just told you what we think you should
do you should sell your house and you
should rent if you want to put the kid
in the school pay off your debts take
your fabulous 300 000 income and start
saving up for a down payment rents are
not you know you you have to get
fatalistic on me every time we talk
about it you have the horrible ghetto
that you live in that's a half million
dollar home that's ridiculous statement
then you have rents are so high that
it's impossible to rent well if you
can't afford to rent in the school
district your kids going to go to you
can't afford to buy in the school
district your kids going to go to so we
have a bit of a problem here Melissa
you're gonna have to decide which of
these things you want to do you can't
have it all you've tried to have it all
and made your life into a freaking mess
you've got hundreds of thousands of
dollars worth of debt never saying no to
you guys so now it's time to say no
stop it stop doing it so either sit
there and pay off your student loan
debts starting today like wild people or
move and rent and use the equity to pay
it off you do whatever you want to do
that's what I would do I have an issue
with this I feel like this is kind of a
trend right now where folks are calling
in and they've said I want that I want
to be a stay-at-home mom and I want to
live in the best school districts and I
want Jimmy to have the best possible and
it's like but if you can't afford it
you've gotta it's got to make sense it's
got to make sense in in the span of your
reality and sometimes you have the
opportunity to make it make sense if
you're willing to sacrifice but you
can't have it all without willing to
shoot that's important I wanted we
wanted to stop this private school
tuition in the case of the example I
just gave and we wanted to get rid of
the IRS after bankruptcy because the IRS
never goes away right we're one of those
people out of our life and we wanted the
kids in a school system
we also wanted to own a house
but we one of those other things more
than owning a house yeah and if you ask
Sharon Ramsey to this day that was uh
gosh it's almost 30 years 25 years ago
okay to this day she can describe the
color
of the kitchen floor in the rental she
hated that house I feel that the hate
that I mean and she can describe all the
things that were wrong with that rental
house that that period of our life was
we made choices about what was most
important the things that were less
important were highly unpleasant yeah I
feel bad and you've got to do the
unpleasant to get to do the pleasant I
feel you can't just have it all at once
it doesn't work that way to your point
there is a limit on math unless you go
unless you're in Congress other than
that the rest of us have to live within
within finite dollar amounts that's
right and and we have to live with the
facts and this arithmetic thing it'll
kick your butt it will yeah oh gosh I
feel that Dave talking about you can
still see the rental
there was a
townhouse that we lived in with
roommates and we used to come in and I
could smell like in my mind now I can
smell walking in the house the roommates
cooking like ground beef or something I
can see the old couch hang up your lip
about ground beef I don't have a problem
with ground beef
I don't like the smell of it Dave I'm
not gonna lie really no I don't you are
kind of a vegan yeah I am but it's just
smell of ground beef smells like dog
food to me that's neither here nor there
but I can see the room I can smell it I
mean gosh as I mean that's good
stay on track Dave
saying smelling ground beef doesn't feel
like a sacrifice to me it smells like
supper to me well look some folks can't
cook I'm saying something
you're too much fun so guys live like no
one else so that later you can live and
give like no one else no discipline
seems Pleasant at the time but it yields
a harvest of righteousness you're gonna
pay a price
to win you need to decide intentionally
which of these prices you want to pay
what's your number one priority what's
your number two priority and then you're
going to take a hurting on your number
three temporarily this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
thank you
hey what's up guys it's Jay if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Jade
warshaw Ramsey personality is my co-host
today open phones here at triple eight
eight two five five two two five Olivia
is with us in Roanoke to start this hour
hi Olivia how are you
Jade how are you great how can we help
good I just want to start off by saying
that I'm actually in FPU Rachel's FPU
class right now so I'm super excited
about that I am a stay-at-home mom to
two-year-old triplet boys whoa
yeah it's it's crazy
my husband is a car salesman
um in Bristol Virginia and so his
commute is about 45 minutes to an hour
um he also has very long hours and so he
leaves the house at seven and gets home
at 9 30. therefore I am by myself with
these three crazy boys
um for that whole time
I just need some guidance as to I'm not
really sure so we he has been a car
salesman for about a year and a half he
is up for a big promotion the CEO has
actually said that he is next in line
for finance Finance school and that
would be a huge raise for us he's making
about a hundred thousand to 115 000
right now and he would be making about
250 to 300. doing what
um being a finance manager a finance
okay yep and at a car dealership okay
um and and I the only reason why I know
those
um numbers is because there's only two
in there and they both make basically
the same money
um so I just need I guess some guidance
for me mentally
um it is really hard I don't want to be
you know have a pity party but it's
really hard on me by myself with three
boys
um and he is never home so I guess you
know I was talking to Rachel about it
and you know I just I don't want him to
lose this opportunity because it is a
season and they will be going to school
you know in a couple of years and I just
it's just really hard right now
um doing it so I guess my my question is
would the finance manager have less
hours or more hours
about business okay
so that would really help us throw on
baby step number two right now
um and well to show the promotion is not
a question the question is whether you
just continue in this career field
correct well is the bigger problem that
he's not around much or is the bigger
problem that you just need help at home
and whoever it is if it's help with a
babysitter coming every once in a while
what's the bigger problem
um it's a little bit
and of course of course you know we
severely miss him but I know that he's
you know he's working for us and for our
future and you know to be able to you
know sit on the beach
anyone who manages three
you know a triplets two years old that
it you know 12 hours a day by yourself
that that's that that that's wild yeah
you're not whining to ask a question
okay that's that's crazy land and um but
now then then and you know the problem
is you've got this other valid thing
that's a valid thing the other valid
thing is 250 000 a year is a pretty dead
gum good deal
um and you know you make it some serious
Bank there uh could you move over there
and you know give you a an hour and a
half back a day get rid of the commute
so yes we actually moved here um from
Richmond Virginia for
um this job opportunity and this was the
first house that we just you know found
because it sure was so it's a stupid
house
okay okay move to Bristol look getting
that time back in a commute is
everything we're in a house next door to
the dealership he can come home for
lunch
yeah yeah absolutely I
agree with that as well I have talked to
him you know there's actually a house
literally like point two miles let's go
and he says well it's on a very big road
and the house is right up on the road I
don't do that house that's not the point
the point is move over there
okay because two hours a day of this is
commute
absolutely and then like you got traffic
jams in freaking Bristol
absolutely no traffic jam this is just a
long way over there
yeah sell the house and move
here show the house and move and hire a
nanny that's what you need look Olivia
when when my my family moved here to
Tennessee and before this I was
basically worked from home I was with my
kids as much as I need to so this was a
big change and we knew going in the
commute needed to be very short I can
meet my husband for lunch the kids can
come by for lunch I'm home in 20 minutes
like that that is everything so I think
we're starting to work some serious
hours yeah so I think starting there is
going to make all the difference in the
world
um and finding ways to bring each other
into your day is is a big part of this
like I said if you guys can meet up for
lunch any of that stuff and like Dave
said having help just having a sitter
come for two hours a day or an hour just
to give you some sanity back because
your mind your mind ain't working right
you know what I mean when you're with
kids like that all day and hey if you're
gonna make it if you're gonna if you're
gonna make an extra 150 000 a year we
can Offset you know we got some money to
spend that's right
yes
spend 20 on a nanny
yeah you're not a spoiled little brat
you're not you deserve that's okay to do
that's the cost of him doing this that's
right yeah now are you guys working
through a lot of debt right now too is
that what's giving you pause
no we have two car payments um and the
mortgage but I guess it's just the fact
that we're you know of course eating
rice and beans beans and rice and just
really trying to
um gung-ho on everything the price for
sanity
is a small price to pay no no I mean
you're netting out okay because your
other option is your other options are
untenable it's not your situation is not
sustainable
okay great 250 at 150 at 350. it's not
sustainable because you're telling
yourself that you've got that message
loud and clear in your head and you're
that is not whining and so what are we
going to do well we're going to take the
promotion we're going to move over there
we're going to take some of that 250 000
that extra 150 000 and we're going to
use it in the hire a nanny and and
that's not whining it's how we're able
to pull this off right you know how does
Rachel and Jade with small children pull
off New York City media appearances and
book launches and doing the show three
hours a day when they're down here to do
it and doing media hits at six o'clock
and five o'clock in the morning on Fox
how do they pull that off help right you
know and so there's a there's an offset
that has to be there to be able to
actually cause that to occur that's
right
um you know
uh you know so that that's how you do it
and I I don't think you're
if I thought you were whining you know
I'd tell you because I love you but I I
don't think you're whining I think this
is a real deal reasonable situation
where you need some help but you guys
need to go okay this is not working what
do we got to change and that's what we
start doing we start get prescribing
changes to you now so I'd get down there
right close to the office very little
commute see him more and I'd hire a
nanny and I'd take the promotion and
then hey a year from now two years from
now if it's still wired up maybe you do
something different but let's give it a
shot this is the Ramsay shot
[Applause]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is budget
friendly biblically based Health cost
sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
C of chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones a triple eight
eight two five five two two five Stacy
is with us in Canada hi Stacy welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hi
for this amazing
thank you how can we help
um husband and my family we live on on a
farm and we pay really cheap rent where
we are because we help out on the ranch
so that's a good situation there so we
ended up buying a Waterfront Lake cone
to leave for a legacy for our kids when
they grow up so we do have that paid off
now so I guess technically we're done
baby step seven so now we're looking at
buying a house instead of staying on
this Ranch forever so I guess the
question is what order should we do this
should we buy a house it would be about
900 000 we'd have to save four or should
we just go ahead and save a quick down
payment on a smaller house in town that
we could rent out and it would pay the
mortgage well we save for our bigger
purchase house
what would you do
what happened to living on the ranch for
reduced rent
oh I would
we just don't
why would you need to do that right I
mean why do you need to buy something
um I guess so our money grows we feel
like that's the way we should do it as
opposed to just saving it in a savings
account
okay
um no I would not buy a rental property
with debt
we don't have any debt no you'd be
buying a rental property with debt
and I would not do that because we don't
want it I would not do that
if you want to if you want to invest in
good mutual funds you can do that
um and then when you're ready to
purchase a home someday you'll have a
big pile of money in your mutual funds
that might be okay okay and you that's
not a savings account and no I would not
park it in a savings account I don't
want a million dollars in a savings
account but you don't have a million
dollars but what's the lake house worth
uh 460 or I think 518 this year okay and
you don't rent it out do you
no it's too uh rustic yeah okay
rustic four hundred thousand dollars
we got a lot of yeah okay
um
uh no I no do not go buy a rental
property with debt which is in essence
everything you asked every question you
ask every way you asked it involved
buying a rental property with that
you're not going to move off the ranch
you're going to stay in the cheap rent
now and you're whatever you were going
to buy you're going to have a mortgage
and whatever you were going to buy you
were going to rent and so whether it was
large or small or 900 or whatever it was
it didn't matter it's all involved no I
would not go into that no absolutely not
I would invest in good mutual funds if
you want to buy some investment property
save up and pay cash for it
but don't buy a piece don't buy an
investment property that you think
you're going to live in 20 years from
now because you won't
chances of you moving in that house 20
years from now is precisely zero
it's actually a good point that we
hadn't really thought of of we're
thinking of picking something out we
would like but yeah that's a really good
point yeah your life is going to change
your dreams are going to change the
dishwasher is going to change technology
is going to change you're not going to
move in that house in 20 years I was
wondering where the 900 no that was the
home she wanted to live in someday got
you got you that was the future the
20-year from or whatever however number
of years we stay on the ranch I don't
know but yeah yeah it took me a minute
to kind of unwind all that you've done a
really good job everything you pay cash
for you've got the uh you know basically
the the parsonage on the ranch so to
speak or you're living there virtually
free and um and you've been piling up
money you've done really really really
good and then you got the real estate
Edge I guess you got on Tick Tock or
something and got the real estate so no
don't don't don't go into that stuff I
mean I love real estate but I love paid
for real estate and that's what I would
tell you to do so
all right open phones here at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
student loan payments oh we'll restart
soon and many borrowers aren't ready
interesting article from CNBC here yes
is uh the more than three year long
pause on federal student loan payments
is slated to finally conclude within
months and we know that they've you know
passed this debt ceiling uh legislation
per se or this deal and part of that
they've said you're not going to extend
this payment pause any longer so we know
let it be known student loans are
resuming wait a minute Did we tell you
that oh yeah we told you that we've been
telling folks this day I told you that
we're going to be forgiven that you're
going to pay them we told you that
didn't we yeah and now it's time to pay
the piper the piper calleth and it's
time to start paying this is the King
James version of Jade yeah
Dave I just I wanted to highlight some
of these numbers because I don't think
people really understood what's taking
place these I mean obviously you know
your payments have been on pause no
interest no payment due in quotes but
this was such a great opportunity to
take advantage most people during this
pause Dave had have saved about fifteen
thousand dollars in payments that's what
they've saved during this time by not
having to pay and what did they do with
them pray tell nothing thing
white let me say fifteen thousand
dollars they don't have fifteen thousand
dollars no they no did they got they
bought hamburgers and and and they
bought expensive lattes
and they bought car payments for seven
hundred and Seventeen dollars that's
what they bought and here's here's
here's where my soul was crushed when I
read only less than one percent
of people continued to make payments
during the pause there is less than one
percent of smart people who took
advantage and said you know what yeah
I'm gonna make payments they're gonna go
straight to the principal I I'm I'm
saving money every month I can put that
back on my debt hit the principal pay it
off
and uh instead a lot of people said you
know what I'm cool with this I'm cool
with the fact that this pause it's free
money right no
it's not free money it was uh you cost
the taxpayers
like a billion right five billion
billion billion
yeah per month per month per month
that's what we that's what I paid for
you people to not have to pay your
student loans
stuff no Dave this is free money
oh there's no such thing yeah five
billion a month for people so that
people could not have to pay their
student loans and and did they use that
to opportunity to get ahead
answer no one one percent less than one
person and here's what the loans down 43
billion people have benefited quote
benefited from the student loan pause 43
43 million what did I say yes thank you
43 million correction and here's my
thing everybody's still whining hoping
that this uh Biden's forgiveness will
come through they want the ten thousand
dollars right they want the twenty
thousand dollars you got 15. and you
squandered it
so no you shouldn't get another 10.
you should not get another 20. you got
15 back and and what did you do I like
the word you you scoundrel you
squandered it you're squandering
scoundrel yeah yes
[Music]
Costco hot dogs going out to eat
a toast that's why come on Chipotle
that's what you spend time my Burgers
all right Chipotle
but the point is these payments are
coming back
and it's time to get in check guys
because it's coming it's knocking on the
door so Brooke's a single mother of two
did nothing and uh as an extra 600 a
month uh is gonna start coming now she
has a hundred thousand dollars in uh uh
I'm sorry no she has 240 000 and she
makes a hundred thousand a year yeah and
she says where's the extra 600 a month
gonna come from less hamburgers
hahaha
this is the Ramsay show get out of here
oh my gosh
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host hey if you're out running around
America
and you're in the Nashville area just
south of Nashville is a wonderful town
called Franklin Tennessee Civil War era
square that you can walk around and
enjoy and one exit south of there you'll
find the Ramsey headquarters which
includes a Lobby and a free homemade
chocolate chip cookies and coffee come
in and visit we do the show on the glass
every uh day from one to four Central
Time and so you can come in and watch
this happen every single day and part of
what happens in the lobby is usually 50
to a couple hundred people sitting
around and part of what happens in the
lobby is also we have this little thing
called the debt free stage and standing
on it our Ivy and John hey guys how are
you good good love having you guys here
where do you live Appleton Wisconsin
Appleton Wisconsin awesomeness and how
much debt have you guys paid off
347 356
000. wow
I love it well done well done how long
did this take it's uh 74 months 74
months and your range of income during
uh anywhere from 80 to 180 000. cool
what do you all do for a living I am a
registered nurse I'm a plumber very good
two great careers well done very good
stuff always in demand to both of you
yeah yeah never without work for sure
whether you want to do it very good so
I'm gonna guess and say in Appleton
Wisconsin on 74 months and 347 you paid
off your house yes
[Applause]
what's this house worth
rough with this Market I don't know I
mean yes just roughly all right
I'd say 300 000. why did you owe 347 on
it it wasn't just the house
everything this is what we paid off yeah
so you live a 300 000 house it's paid
for yes and we paid off what other kind
of debt well so I started back in 2012
of I owed I had all of the debt I had
the student loans the car payment the
credit cards I was diagnosed with
multiple sclerosis back in 2004 so
medical debt and then I had a very short
marriage in which I paid a lot of money
so divorce debt huh later that year I
was kind of wondering what I should do
financially wise and in the bulletin at
church was an advertisement for your
class there you go so I didn't know how
I was going to pay for your class when
did John come along a couple years later
I was hoping he was in the financial
peace class he's just waiting on you we
took it together again again okay all
right I started working here it's
romantic I'm not sure but yeah it's
something
no I started doing it and I met John
later that year actually we got married
in 2014. excellent uh but we didn't do
our finances together oh how long before
you did that two years okay two years
this was a journey this was a journey so
in 2016 is when we started with the
gazelle intensity uh I'll let you know I
have a question yeah sure I want to know
what happened to make you guys get on
the same page I mean two years of doing
your finances is separate then what was
what what pushed you together well one I
had my own business for 10 years before
roughly 10 years before I
yeah sold the tools in the truck
um
but I guess it came to
he wanted to buy a brand new work truck
and it scared me got it at the time it
was going to be a 60 000 truck probably
much more than that now
um but we kind of kept the business and
the personal stuff separated and the
whole idea of a car payment a truck
payment on a business where he was his
only employee scared me so you were like
I gotta be able to control this a little
bit
before we buy a truck can we go take
Financial Peace University again because
you're kind of hard to explain to people
you flunked yeah okay I got it yeah no I
know you said again I never took it well
that was your first one that was my
first okay yeah so it wasn't again for
him oh but I wanted him to experience
the whole experience so we knew I could
talk him out of it right and you didn't
yeah that's pretty much what happened it
Liz please don't buy a truck till you
talk to Dave
into that I think it was a trick John
all right so very cool now you're 100
free yes now obviously you're doing
really well with the MS yeah yeah I
actually found out that a lot of it
um the really expensive stuff the drugs
doesn't work for me so
um diet and exercise so and stress
well no more money stress there you go
that's a big deal I've got a good friend
that has been dealing with it for about
20 years and they keep her stress level
down and her fatigue keep her from
getting fatigued and she does great yeah
and and is doing no drugs yep yeah but I
mean it's different for different
patients I understand I'm not MediCal
you are but but um I mean you're
obviously doing great congratulations
I'm proud for you very cool guys very
cool congratulations how does it feel to
be a hundred percent free 11 years into
marriage awesome really good no debt of
any kind yeah it's weird so rich but
unbelievable how much is in your uh Nest
Egg already oh so you missed that part
of the story John will tell you that
part of the story okay your retirement
what you did with your business
or a mistake way back yeah
um so my I worked for a company as a
plumber and then when I started my
business things were financially not
that great I
end up create or
you cashed it cashed it in which learned
it wasn't supposed to be doing that
but it's nowhere
so where are you now what's your next
egg now between the two of you
we just look at it where could we be no
it's a journey
no no I mean I I could have been a
slumlord I could have kept a bunch of
lower income real estate that I had and
it's all gone and I went bankrupt I
could be there thank God I'm not you
know I mean life is you could be a lot
of places but now you guys are together
you got a great marriage you're smiling
you're fun you have a paid for house and
you're almost Millionaires and you're
still young pups well done very well
done I'm proud of you good good work wow
very cool yeah love I love to hear it
okay what do you tell people when
somebody asks and they say okay how'd
you do that what do you tell them the
key
to getting out of debt and Building
Wealth is you have to talk to the other
person about money
I mean we tried that the first couple
years of our marriage and it didn't work
there's some pretty stressful
conversations that are had you have to
have them yes uh yeah if you buy a truck
I'm gonna kill you oh yeah that one now
well not quite that you would never say
something like that
just slow death
pretty much so yeah it's really the
difficult conversations yeah that you
don't want to have and they're tough so
but it's worth going through that coming
out on the other side of that yeah
there's an incredible peace and
cleanliness that comes with complete
openness complete Unity we're dialed in
we're doing everything together making
decisions together
even though sometimes it causes some
momentary discomfort the long-term
benefits are unbelievable they're very
good yeah so I'm so proud of y'all
thanks thank excellent job excellent job
you're while we come down here very very
cool good stuff all right it's Ivy and
John Appleton Wisconsin quite the
journey everything's paid off baby step
seven house and everything approaching
baby steps millionaires status 347 000
paid off in 74 months making 80 to 180
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one
[Applause]
yeah get it I like it powerful stuff
great hey we've got the live and give
bundle for them that includes The Total
Money Makeover book The Baby Steps
millionaires book and another Financial
Peace University membership they'll be
able to give those things or keep them
for themselves elves everyone who comes
and does it that free scream gets that
this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
personality is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five we're glad you're here
Susie's with us in Virginia hi Susie
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi hey what's up I was like I would like
to thank you first of all for sharing
um
sharing everything that you've learned
to help others have Financial Freedom
well thank you
um I
my husband and I had listened to the
show for a couple years and we had
applied some of your teachings in the
baby steps and
um we kind of forgot an important one
um we
we had paid off all of our debt and we
were working he was throwing everything
at the house and
um he unexpectedly passed away in
September of last year oh my goodness
how old was he
well he was 67. oh my
God and how long were you all married
it was 20 20 years
um
[Music]
a very unexpected he had been to the
doctor and the doctors gave him you know
a clean bill of health and you know I
knew and he knew
that something was not right but
ultimately he had an LLC we had three
different locations convenience stores
and I was thrown
into a whirlwind and mourning for my
husband at the same time
um but the good news is is the business
had an emergency fund and so I was able
to keep the business of the float really
not knowing
technically I just always assist with
him I never he was an accountant and he
had a business degree and he had Run
convenience stores for 40 years so I was
just
the assistant wife but
we only had debt on the house
um
it was amazing because the months before
he passed his life insurance policy ran
up ran out and he was like honey
it my rate's going to go up
and I was like no don't pay it you're
just fine and so
um listening to your show he knew how
important it was because you did have a
business and we have one more child that
is
um she's getting she just graduated high
school and so she wanted to go to
college and so he felt like he needed to
have this
and so he paid the extra high premium on
the life insurance
and then less than 30 days he had passed
wow so
um I ran the locations for five months
um we didn't have a plan he
unfortunately did not have a will
um so I'm dealing with probate
um like I told you before
um
we were best buds did you did you get
the stores sold
and so that's why I called you because
um I just wanted to thank you because
you know we
we did not have any debt and we were
following through with the plan but then
yet we were missing two bigger pieces of
what happens if and so
um he gave I just randomly asked him one
day how much the locations that he you
know how much do you think that they're
worth running if you know and so I had
an idea and the people came and they
bought the store and they it was a
blessing the award was involved in all
of it because I really didn't all of the
numbers were up in his head nothing was
written down but
there I am now I've been mourning for
nine months I ran those doors for five
so I've taken it's been about four
months and I'm ready to start dealing
with all of the money that it is in the
bank so how much do the stores sell for
ah
um
almost a million wow and how much was
the life insurance because each location
had about a hundred how much was the
life insurance
it was
a 500. okay so you're sitting on 1.5 now
well I had to I had to pay off the house
okay good nothing wrong with it
so how much have you got left
um about a million
over okay that's crazy how old are you
yeah
oh I'm 44. oh okay you got all kinds of
time okay cool
so
I I guess
financial advisors and I called them and
and then I met with another
and so my question is yesterday I was
kind of impulsive and because I feel
like the money that's sitting in there
um I feel like it's just um it's not
growing and I feel like it's not but
it's don't but don't get impulsive or
Panic take your time
get with someone that has the heart of a
teacher did you meet with a smartvester
pro
and that wasn't what I was asking so the
first meeting you don't need to make a
decision you're just meeting them you're
interviewing them
how did you feel
feel not what did you think how did you
feel when you walked out of there after
meeting that person
a listening
okay because my heart's desires
listen you got to go with that so go
back on the website pick out another
smart investor Pro and go sit down you
need to have a sense that they have the
heart of a teacher or you don't work
with them and let me tell you right now
you're a walking raw nerve because of
what you've been through
and so you're feeling the reason I asked
that very specific question is you're
you're feeling things at a heightened
level of awareness
there's a lot of pain and a lot of
um fear of making a mistake
there's a and all of this is heightened
and so there's a your nerve endings are
all are all chattering they're going
right am I wrong correct no you are so
right yeah and so just breathe
and what you need to have is a sense of
peace
and a sense of uh you're dealing with a
solid person with the heart of a teacher
yeah and when you talk to these
investment professionals if they don't
want to answer your questions or if they
make you feel like what you're asking is
silly or you've asked too many questions
for me that's a red flag to go to
someone else because that's why they're
there they're there to to help teach you
help guide you and you should feel like
I can ask I can you know
I can speak to them and they're not
making me feel silly or dumb for what
I'm asking it might be that the other
smart investor Pro that you worked that
you met with is excellent at their work
they are not excellent for you at this
moment in your time because you're in a
very unique situation and you've got to
have someone that's slows everything
down right now
take your time you don't take two years
but you don't take two minutes either
just slow down
you need to walk through this and it
needs to feel like you're walking
downstairs in the dark and you hadn't
turned on the light you're going to feel
that step before you take the next step
and feel that step before you take the
next step put my foot on solid stuff
you hearing me hey
yes you're gonna be fine you're gonna be
fine you are wise
and uh you don't need to apologize for
not behaving the business or the
accounting background the lady that I've
just heard her story performed
beautifully in a high stress environment
I think you did an amazing job and so
you can trust you you are trustworthy
you're worthy of trust Susie look in the
mirror you can do this and if you need
help you call here any time we're here
to help you and if you need some more
help if you want to get with our team
I'll tell you what let's do this hook
her up with the guys upstairs that run
smart Mister Pro and make sure that she
sits down with the right one just have
our guys let's just do a hand in glove
White Glove experience here okay let's
just make sure there's some Widow seems
to be taken care of No Charge there we
go that's why I love working here Dave
they're right there that's the way we do
it this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships thank you
for joining us America Jade warshaw
Ramsay personality is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life and your money open phones here at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five thank you for being with us Jose
starts off this hour in Fayetteville
Arkansas hey Jose how are you
hey Mr renzi and Mr J how are you all
today great man how can we help
yes sir well I just want to start real
quick by thanking your entire team I met
most of y'all at the Smart conference
for your grand opening and what a fun
event so thank you all for what you do
well thank you man appreciate you coming
over to Nashville for that
thank you sir it was a great great trip
cool how can we help today
yes sir uh so uh I'll start right off
the bat uh so uh I just left my uh nine
to five uh my nine-to-five job and uh I
can just hit the manager and I just due
to poor leadership and uh I went ahead
and uh started my own Remodeling and
handyman services company brought off uh
back to back within a week so I'm just
calling for some wisdom
um you know I I just need to you know
get some do's and don'ts from you but uh
yeah I mean I'm uh need to do some
coaching okay on on leadership on money
what are we talking about here
uh I I would say I mean uh finances uh I
guess start off this would be my second
Venture uh I've done the food check
before uh it went well I sold it uh to
get my house uh but right now I'm on
baby step two and uh yeah uh starting
off you know fresh uh with my second
Venture now as a remodeler and handyman
so yeah I mean finances uh any boy was
that is it just you in the business or
do you have
other folks that are working with your
Contracting
uh yeah right now it's just me uh just
myself yeah uh uh looking to you know
see if I can hire up uh in in the near
future but okay so you feel confident
about estimating the jobs into in such a
way that the pricing is fair but you
make a profit
that is right sir yeah okay all right so
what I would tell you then is make sure
the first thing you do if you haven't
already done is open a business checking
account it doesn't have to be
complicated it can be just a DBA account
um Jose DBA doing business as Jose's
Remodeling Company or whatever and it's
just social security number you don't
even have to have a tax ID number to do
that you can if you want but it's not
necessary and then make sure 100 of the
income of the business goes into that
account and the only thing you pay out
of that account are expenses
what's left by definition if Revenue
minus expenses is what's left in the
account by definition your account
balance is your profit
okay yeah on a simple Cash basis
accounting system is what you're
creating there okay now when you pull
money out of that account to take it
home to pay bills and eat and all those
glorious things you need to also set
aside one-fourth of everything you pull
out of that account
so if you pull a thousand dollars out
you set aside 250 dollars and set that
in a separate savings account that you
have labeled taxes so that you can pay
your quarterly estimates and um until
you make about a hundred thousand profit
your quarterly estimates are going to be
right around 25 percent
because your net tax rate your net tax
rate is going to be a little over 10 and
you got 15.3 because you get the
opportunity to pay both sides of FICA
called self-employment tax because small
business people pay double tax
so um yeah and so yeah because we in
America and Washington DC really
believes in small business so they tax
you twice so the gift of business
ownership yeah that's it so yeah that's
what you do and and so yeah you set
aside a fourth for taxes you pay your
quarterly estimates on time and then the
trick here is of course to manage the
estimating process and uh man I'd pick
me up some software to do that some
estimating software and build it into an
accounting system if you can it's not
real complicated to do so that you track
how close you closely you and accurately
you do that and you charge all of your
tools and all of your purchases to a job
job cost everything
ah okay that's great and that way you
say okay that job was you know I had to
buy an extra tool that was X number of
dollars to do this job and this job
bought the tool and I still made a
profit
okay that way you don't end up taking
all your money and buying tools because
in your business you can just buy tools
for everything you know I mean you buy
tools for days
yeah last night I was at Home Depot and
uh of course I'm pretty sure you've seen
the Milwaukee packout system and uh I'm
like I need to go home just relax think
about it and then I'm like well I don't
need to spend you know a thousand
dollars after that yeah let a job buy
that for you
yeah some job where you'll actually
utilize that because that's a great
system by the way I love the Milwaukee
stuff but um I'm a tool on that but the
uh uh yeah jump in there get but but let
a job pay for it and that way you're not
just a boy collecting goodies
I see okay
um last uh I guess last uh uh question
would be uh uh uh you know I do listen
to the entrep Entre leadership and uh
for leadership purposes uh I'm trying to
you know gradually and grow a better
leader just so that when the day do the
best time when I need to hire
um just you know uh of course uh you
said uh really great uh example there at
their you know resin Solutions so just
uh you know a couple uh you know he's
the wisdom that I can use for muscle
build in your situation it sounds like
the first type of hire probably wouldn't
be like a fuller part-time person it'd
probably be just a contracted worker if
you're it's a handyman business so you
might be hiring a guy that does a
specific task and you're just hiring him
to do that task for that job and maybe
you know you've worked out something
where he's coming back to you uh just to
do that type of Labor I I don't see how
right away you'd be making uh you know a
payroll higher unless it was somebody to
do bookkeeping or something like that or
you know do the office end of things and
that might be on down the line I mean
you got to have so much work that you're
covered up and can't simply can't get to
it and then you can justify payroll
position but yeah in terms of how you
treat people I mean I think we all
learned from the time we got peed on
right
that time you went to work and they got
pissed on you I mean you know you know
you're not going to do that so I had a
guy cussed me out when I was in my 20
early 20s and fire me yelling F-bomb at
me the whole time I still don't know
what I did
I still don't know why I got fired I
probably actually deserved it but I
don't know what I did I just want to
meet the man that cussed out Dave Ramsey
I was 20 years old I was kind of a cat
aghast I was just caught off guard and
I'm like okay okay I get it I'm out of
here I'm done okay I'll clean up my desk
it's okay but I still don't know what I
did to this day and he died so I still
I'll never know but the uh but so you
know out of that what did I learn wow I
have you know I've had uh over the years
we've you know we've got 1100 team
members we've probably got 1500 people
that used to work here that either left
and got better jobs or got married and
moved to Oklahoma or some of them we
fired but every single person we fired
knows why and none of them were cussed
in the process so I just decided I'm not
going to treat other people like I got
treated so treat other people like you
want to be treated Golden Rule The
Golden Rule I mean it's not hard and so
just be kind and gentle and courageous
and firm and truthful treat other people
like you'd want to be treated pay your
you tell them you're gonna pay them pay
them
you tell them they need to do something
make sure they do it you know treat
other people like you don't be treated
and to be unclear is to be unkind
this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
guarantee and bring is always free see
whyblinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings go
to blinds.com now and save 40 percent
off selected products visit blinds.com
today for more info
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host if you're a
business leader there's something you
need to know all the best leaders spend
time and yes some money investing in
their own growth as our friend John
Maxwell likes to say leadership ability
is the lid that determines a person's
level of Effectiveness you've got to
invest in yourself if you want to grow
and what better way to do that than to
attend the premier leadership conference
of the year
entree Leadership Summit we just
finished the one that we did this year
last week here at the Nashville uh
Gaylord hotel and uh next year we're
going to be in Dallas you're going to be
challenged and motivated by the top
Minds in leadership people like James
Clear from oh man from Atomic habits is
going to be speaking Craig groeschel
Pastor Craig pastor of America's largest
church arguably and one of the founders
of the YouVersion Bible app with a half
a billion downloads now Craig is an
incredible leadership speaker and a good
friend Mike Rowe from Dirty Jobs and
Deadliest Catch will be there Carrie
Lawrence America's first female fighter
pilot and is she inspiring I'm telling
you some guy named Dave Ramsey will be
there so you never know about that guy
but uh Hey the rest of them probably
going to be pretty good and next year's
summit's 10-year anniversary of this
we've been doing it and we're taking it
to the Gaylord Texan in Dallas celebrate
if you want to grow your leadership
ability and celebrate all that you've
accomplished as a leader so far you need
to join us it's going to be an
incredible week April 21st through the
24th incredible three days actually
seriously if there's a year to be there
it's this one you do not want to miss
this to learn more go to
ramseysolutions.com
Summit
ramsesolutions.com
Summit our question of the day sponsored
by neighborly your hub for Home Services
if you're moving you have a long list of
to Do's but neighborly has local Pros
like house Master 5 Star painting window
Genie and Junk King and uh one of the Mr
Electric guys dropped by the lobby here
a little bit earlier from neighborly
yeah pretty cool so visit neighborly.com
to schedule Home Service Experts near
you today's question of the day comes
from Tony in Michigan he says I'm 56
years old and have no debt I have 1.4
million in the bank and want to know how
much is enough for me to feel
comfortable retiring 1.4 million sounds
like a lot but I don't have a good
handle on how long that would last
that's a really good question
um Dave and I feel like a lot of people
kind of have that thought in their mind
I've got this money how do I know if
it's enough how do I how do I know if I
can retire or when I can retire and I
feel like it's more about being able to
and being happy with living off the
interest so if you looked at 1.4 million
and it's invested let's say that you're
averaging a 10 10 rate of return are you
able to live on the 10 comfortably with
inflation with all of your expenses so
in his case 140 000 a year
does that feel right if you feel like
yes then great it'll last forever it'll
last forever because you're never
touching the principle yeah nobody
playing the golden eggs that's right and
and that's really where you want to be
you don't ever want to have to touch
that money
um but if you're looking at that and
you're like oh I don't know like living
on 140 000 I've been living off of 200
if you've got a house payment there's so
many things to consider but that's
ultimately at the end of the day what we
want to be looking at is living off the
interest and if that's possible for you
so yeah and here's a simple equation and
it is probably overly simple but just to
kind of give you an idea all right
inflation not counting lately or
counting lately actually and for the
last 75 years has averaged four percent
four point two percent okay now lately
we've been closer to ten sure and in the
70s we were 12 but the average
over the last 75 years is 4.2 all right
now the average stock market rate of
return is 11.8
since the stock market began that's the
average annual return if you had
invested in growth stock mutual funds
across the stock market okay now so if
we just use rough numbers let's say 12
percent rate of return which my personal
mutual funds have averaged that from
decades now so averaged some years not
some years a lot more average that's
right sixth grade math can you explain
average because I know all the time
people fight us on on that the
difference between annual or like
annualized rate of return looking at it
over the track record of it just just
look at and say what did you make okay
because this is how wealthy people look
at they go all right if I'm making 12
and I'm losing 4 in purchasing power
because of inflation the cost of bread
went up the cost of electricity went up
the cost of cars and tires went up the
cost of dot dot dot went up four percent
so if I'm making 12 and I'm losing 4 or
in purchasing power if I pull off eight
my mutual funds will grow by four a year
but they have to do that to break even
in purchasing power
so if you're earning 12 and pulling off
four you're getting a cost of living
raise that's good every year
but it's a cost of living raise it's not
anymore you're not you're not gaining
actual wealth right it's net of
inflation you're gaining but you're
gaining actual dollars to offset the
inflation okay so if if and if you did
that and if you want to use different
numbers use different numbers use 11 and
and five then you'd pull off six okay I
don't care but that's how you can go
ahead so if you got a million dollars
and you pull off eight that's eighty
thousand that means you made 120 so your
million grew by 40 000 and you lived on
the 80 then so if you can live off of
eight percent and you're invested in
good mutual funds you'll probably pretty
much do it in perpetuation
um it might dip into it a little and it
might refill in another year yeah but
overall it'll pretty much run it'll
pretty much run like a machine the rest
of your life assuming that the you know
the American economy continues to do
what it has done for the last 80 years
well this is one of those reasons it's
so important to do what we teach pay off
your debt pay off your mortgage so that
when you're going into retirement your
ex your cost of living is not Sky High
right and let me tell you something else
here there are some really stupid people
that write Financial articles all over
the Internet and here's here's what's
stupid about them all right they run all
these numbers out in great detail on
math and they do not grasp that life
will never
ever happen the way they laid it out so
the way we just laid this out do you
think that you got the chances that
guy's 1.4 million that he's going to
live on exactly 140 or exactly eight
percent of that right which would be
more like a hundred okay is he actually
gonna do it exactly that way are those
mutual funds going to earn exactly a
market rate of return are they going to
make a little more or a little less
that's right what's going to actually
happen is he's probably going to live on
less than that and this money is going
to grow and there's some other factors
that we haven't even considered in this
like his life and his health and his
marriage and you know and inheritance
comes or doesn't come in addition to
this there's all kinds of other crap
that's going to happen and so these guys
when they're writing these Financial
articles act like well I mean if you
miss this by point two percent you're
not going to make it you're you can't
estimate this you can't forecast it
within 0.2 percent if you're you know
unless you're God you don't know what's
going to happen right and I promise you
God is Not not writing Financial
articles
on Tic Tac okay it's definitely not
happening so I can tell because the
people doing it are idiots and God's
fairly smart so the point is these guys
are become such math nerds they think
all this stuff operates in an exact
little vacuum and it never works out
that way I mean can you imagine if today
with you know I've got hundreds of
millions of dollars worth of real estate
today
that was none of that was in my equation
right
none of it yeah I mean so I mean all you
do is like be one piece of real estate
off that's right and the whole thing
changes so you know you're in one way or
the other uh one business that you sell
yeah or that uh has a hit and Booms uh
one little thing so you can't you're 30
years old you can't predict when you're
70 exactly where you're going to be but
you can have a Target that's right and
say based on that Target I know that if
I'm 25 years old and I average 12
percent and I put a hundred dollars a
month away from age 25 to age 65 that
the math tells me that's one million one
hundred and seventy six thousand dollars
is it going to happen exactly that way I
just said it wasn't
but that's what the math can predict for
you it can go oh so we could have over a
million dollars we have hope we're not
going to wait on uh Karl Marx and
socialism to fix this right we're
actually going to work and save and live
on less than we make and be on a budget
and keep our butts out of debt this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place here's
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today okay
and set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
Jade watch all Ramsay personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions a packed house and on the debt
freeze scream April is with us hi April
how are you hi Dave hi Jade hey where do
you live I live in Harker Heights Texas
it's about 45 minutes north of Austin
outside of Fort Hood yeah okay very cool
very cool welcome to Nashville and how
much debt have you paid April uh 740 000
619 no wow
oh whoa okay and uh how long does this
take uh four years eight months and two
days good Lord girl and your range of
income during that uh four years uh it
was one thirty four thousand to one
fifty one thousand last year wow okay
you did not make enough to do that in
four years well you must have sold
something big yes I had uh the two
rental homes uh from previous Duty
stations uh like so you're military yes
sir thank you for your service what are
you doing the military uh I am retired
as of July 1st I'm a retired uh
Blackhawk pilot say what
girl you're ba
serious wow I'm retired now we're hey
we're in the presence of uh royalty here
oh man okay she can take both of us down
deep deep respect right here yeah well
done very cool and 700 oh and go ahead
and now get the helicopter on the
T-shirt okay yeah 740 000 bucks and how
much of that was the rental property uh
it was 425. okay what are you gonna do
now that you've retired uh I took a year
off I had a um I'm taking a year off I'm
taking a gap year I had a best friend
get married my son graduated college in
high school last month and uh so I'm
gonna I'm gonna do my debt free scream
and then figure out what I want to be
when I grow up wow and I can do that now
very cool I'm proud of you very good
well we're honored to have you here what
an incredible story you are so okay so
you sell off the rental properties what
started all this how'd you get started
on this uh so
um 2018 I was passovers for the second
time for me major and in the military
officer and when you get passed over two
times a year get kicked out in seven
months so for the first time I wrote
down all my debts say what kind of job
what kind of salary do I need in the
civilian world and I'm a single mom so
it's very important to me and at the
first time that's how much I realized I
was in debt and I always wanted to get
into criminal justice so I needed
obviously a six-figure job and you know
starting in criminal justice jobs wasn't
that so they're killed two dreams and
then I was worried that I might have to
claim bankruptcy which my parents
claimed bankruptcy when I was growing up
and I vowed to never do that and so
um I decided to do one of those debt
consolidation things and then I was
talking to a friend of mine from flight
school who is an Apache pilot in
Colorado named Lena and she was passed
over as well and so we were kind of
bonding over it that we were getting out
we were getting stressed and she says
well hey I'm gonna start doing this Dave
Ramsey plan like what is that so I let
you up online and saw you had books and
I saw the website and I'm like I'm not
buying I'm not giving him my money right
now so I went to the library uh checked
out the book and I read it that night
that night was April 21st 2018 and I was
hooked ever since
I
bought every yearbook since then and I
was doing it on my own until
um uh turns out uh so the Army needed us
to stay so they offer me silicon so they
were going to let me finish to my 20
which got me to July 1st 2022. so I was
able to stay
um and but at that point in time I was
like well I don't want to be in that
situation again in five years five years
is going to pass anyways so I might as
well be out of debt so I was I buckled
down uh rice and beans luckily that's
all my son likes so we kind of like that
on that
um I was stationed in Pennsylvania at
the time we moved to Texas in 2019 and
2020 we were during covid we were
quarantined for about six weeks at Fort
Hood and uh during that time I was a
marathon listening to your show and I
heard that there was a free financial
coaching call so I signed up for that
Caroline called me that night which is
actually April 21st 2020 exactly
Caroline is one of your Ramsay Financial
coaches yes sir wow
actually it was two day the two years to
the day April 21st 2020 is when she
called me back
it's actually my free call ended up
being like the three or four hours we
just talked and um bonded over that she
talked me into going to FPU I'm a
self-learner I like to read and I was
like I already read it there's I can't
get nothing at a few but in feu I've
taken FPU 17 times since whoa
17. yes sir and I thought it twice oh my
gosh thank you for teaching it so what
did uh was she right obviously if you
went 17 freaking times but what do you
get from FPU didn't get from Reading
um I I say it's kind of like my AAA
meeting I you know I show up and that
way I'm in I have a group of people that
are like me because when you go around
uh to work saying uh get rid of your
credit cards and and uh no one really
it's so weird no one really wants to
accept that yet so I feel alone at work
you got to get a group of people that
are doing the same thing you're doing
and that's what it is the tribe yes sir
and after after a couple of times ago I
and I just love watching people grow
over how does it feel to be completely
free oh it's such a weight lifted and
you're such a precise person every date
is memorized I mean Blackhawk pilot you
don't you don't miss any detail
everything's dialed in but have you have
you dialed in the feeling and like
that wasn't in the checklist in the baby
steps sir I'm a checklist person it's a
flight it's a flight checklist whatever
okay at baby step seven when you have no
debt and you can breathe you're supposed
to breathe oh okay there's that part
yeah breathe you need to add that into
FPS okay all right
man I love it you're so intense so very
well done yeah now how does it feel
I have a legacy behind my son actually I
tricked him into doing the uh the high
school foundations I bought it for him
for Christmas and I said hey when you
finish this course there's a hundred
dollars waiting for you he he waited
till the last minute to do it but once
he did it he has a notebook full of
notes on the course and then he said he
wanted to be fbu he said he wanted a
part he went and got a part-time job and
started his own Ira at 16. so here we go
dude well done wow yeah you've changed
your family tree yes sir yeah you did
way to go I'm so proud of you I'm so
proud of you okay now when you're
coordinating those classes with paying
off 740 000 bucks what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
the key to getting out of debt but for
me since it was a long time the number
one thing is coffee
never two second grade uh math skills
and three
three grade math skills come on and tell
the truth yes you gotta hate debt you
can't love it because when you're in
love you overlook things like but when
you hate something or you can't stand
like everyone hasn't been able to stand
a co-worker and you know his schedule
you know if he's 30 seconds late to work
okay you follow him and that's what you
have to do I think this is personal for
you I know right I don't even know who
this guy is I'm worried about him okay I
don't want to be on your bad side yeah
it's not it's not good yeah speaking for
a friend she's got details I'm just
saying I've got a plan you're amazing
you're amazing very well done I feel if
there's a few more you out there I think
we in America are well protected
oh my goodness B.A wow unbelievable
Blackhawk ah thank you for your service
thank you thank you and thank you for
your incredible story and your
inspiration you're an inspiring yes
young woman and um you know to to say
thank you for serving and to say uh
thank you for uh leading Financial Peace
University twice and uh going through it
17 times and walking with your coach uh
we want to offer to train you to become
a Ramsey coach would you do that if I
pay for it
all right
[Applause]
that's it all right good deal and we got
this books and stuff too for you too but
I think you've already bought them all
right so yes sir oh my God so yeah I
mean to have somebody like you out there
coaching for Ramsay I know right look
out look out Visa look out Visa I'm just
saying you're going down she got tabs on
you look out Sally May you in danger all
right April from killing Texas wow 740
000 paid off in four years and eight
months selling the rental properties and
doing it making 134 to 151 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
[Music]
almost made a Blackhawk pilot cry I saw
it this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
21 11 when a scoffer is punished the
simple becomes wise when a wise man is
instructed he gains knowledge
Eleanor Roosevelt said learn from the
mistakes of others you can't live long
enough to make them all
that's good that's good that is good
pretty good I'll take that one hey back
at the first of the year we told you the
housing market was not going to melt
down it didn't
we told you the market was going to slow
down it did
and we told you that we were going to
continue to see a slight rise in values
and prices and they have we told you
there's going to continue to be a
shortage of real estate and there is
interest rates have continued to go up
and everybody's walking around with
their lips stuck out but real estate's
still selling
and houses are still selling if you're
getting ready to sell a house it's a
great time to sell a house if you're
getting ready to buy a house great time
to buy a house if you want to refinance
and get rid of the higher interest rated
for rates go down you could do that
later but this is you know you're not
going to get a better deal four years
from now
it's going to be higher
this is the time if you're ready to buy
to buy and you need a Ramsay trusted
agent by your side these guys and gals
got your team's stamp of got our team
stamp of approval because they are
top-tiered real estate agents that you
can trust to handle something important
they're not brand new they do a lot of
transactions we've vetted them we've
done our very best to find the best
possible people we can endorse they're
endorsed local providers for real estate
and their Ramsey trusted go to
ramseysolutions.com agent
to connect to one near you doesn't cost
a thing to connect to them that's
ramsesolutions.com
agent Brandy is in Sacramento hi Brandy
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave hey what's up
hi I I am thank you first of all for
taking my call
um so to get straight to it I inherited
my grandmother's home she passed away in
October of 21. I'm sure we only thank
you um we only have property tax so the
house is paid off
um this is a 30 plus year old home
that's needing Improvement my husband
and I both work full-time we have five
beautiful children to provide and care
for we are in debt a little over 45
000 and are looking to are you living in
the house yes okay what were you paying
before in rent
I know and what you're paying
uh 13.50 okay all right and what do you
guys make what's your household income
73-62
okay so 85 000 a year income all right
and
um and you have 45 000 worth of debt
what kind of debt
um most of it is mine I did purchase a
vehicle so I have 25
um left and then 13 in student loans
okay and then the rest is like um and
what are the repairs to the house that
you want to do
I'm not well there
before and
um that would be meeting replaced or
upgraded it's more energy efficient
and what's the cost of all that heavy
kind of priced it out to see what that
would cost you
yeah
um flooring no windows between it's like
eight to ten thousand
what we were looking at I am reaching
out to like PG me in our area to see if
there's any weatherization programs that
they have
okay and so your net question is what
refinancing or HELOC
and was wondering what your thoughts
were on that you have a paid for house
if you go get a mortgage on it I'm gonna
smack you okay so and I'm gonna watch
that would be a no okay no your
grandmother will come back and haunt no
yeah no absolutely you sell your car is
what you do uh-huh
sell the car uh-huh
you have a paid for house
yeah yeah
and you're a car you can't afford
yeah if you got rid of 800 payment yeah
oh girl yeah
and and a 1300 rent that you don't have
any more that's two thousand dollars a
month and very quickly you could buy
eight thousand dollars worth of windows
okay and very quickly you could knock
out that 13 000 of student loans soon
after okay you could be debt free have
the windows paid off fix the floor all
in a little over a year and be driving a
five thousand dollar paid for car I'd
rather have that and a paid for house
with Windows than I would a stupid car
and see here's what's gonna happen with
this the difference between you cash
flowing this is you if you cash flowing
this means I'm getting the windows I
need and I'm getting the floors I need
you taking out a HELOC is also an excuse
for well let's just go ahead and
renovate the downstairs and let's just
go ahead because that's what happens
people pull that money and in their mind
it's like it's like free free money
right and it's an excuse to do this and
that well it's for the house it's but I
mean let's think about where you could
be three years from now completely
renovated house and 100 debt free
holy crud yeah it ain't bad that's a
good place to aim at and there from
there you could really build some
serious wealth I mean you could have
paid for a house in Sacramento freak in
California yeah that's no slides a big
deal it is a big deal
let's don't let's don't mess this up in
the name in the name of a dead gum car
not a chance all right Kendall is with
us Kendall's in Spokane hi Kendall how
are you
hi I'm good thanks for taking my call
sure what's up
I was just wondering about
how much taxes you think
individual stock or if I should just
leave it alone where it's at where'd you
get the individual stock
it was um gifted to me by my
grandparents when I was born and I
okay your basis in the stock is what
they paid for it you'll pay taxes on the
difference in what they paid for it and
the current sale break do you have any
idea what it was what they paid for it
I
I were on top of that okay yeah I mean
so you're probably the vast majority of
What's the total value of all of that
okay you you probably have 15 tax on
almost all of it it's capital gain it's
capital gains rate and so you know you
probably got a six or eight thousand
dollar tax bill and yes I would and yes
I would cash it in and use it for
wherever you are on the baby steps
okay we're yeah just about to finish
baby stuff too yeah so if you had forty
thousand dollars sitting in the middle
of the table you would not go buy this
stock
correct and so by keeping it you're
making the decision to buy it again
every day
okay so I'm just reverse engineering for
you here that's all we're doing okay
that sets you up and you can go I it
I think everyone hates taxes so bad that
it it sometimes will keep you from doing
what you're supposed to do because you
might have to pay a little tax but I
mean it's a forty thousand dollar gift
yeah and you net out you know 34 or 35
or whatever it ends up being exactly
um after taxes yeah and you get to clean
up your whole mess and move on if you're
using that to take leap leaps forward in
the debt free Journey
it uh it causes your grandparents who
gave that to you to smile that's right
it's worth it and that's what they'd
want you to do with it I think yeah it's
good as long as you're as long as you're
not being you know we're not we're not
cashing out to buy a car right we're not
catching up to go on vacation and waste
it we're cashing out to move forward in
our financial plan and that's what I
hope she's doing with it yeah that's
that's the whole whole process there
very very well done good stuff
yeah and so yeah when you're analyzing
this now there's sometimes you want to
look at the taxes and the penalties and
stuff and like we tell you don't Cash
Out 401ks oh of course never that yeah
yeah
Ramsay personality was my co-host today
that about puts this particular
hour of the Ramsay show in the books
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Applause]
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]